history could be made today on the other
side of the solar system
this afternoon a nasa spacecraft will
make a daring attempt
to collect a sample from an asteroid and
then bring it back to earth
if successful this would be the space
agency's largest return of
extraterrestrial material
since the apollo program brought back
rocks and dust from the moon
the asteroid named bennu is about as
tall as the empire
state building mark strassman got an
inside look
at the mission from earth it's a pin
prick of light in a telescope but 200
million miles away
an asteroid named bennu could hold clues
to the birth of our solar system
the oldest material that you could ever
hold in your hand
is a chunk of an asteroid from outer
space dante loretta's talking about
material
that's four and a half billion years old
he's leading nasa's first ever mission
to retrieve a sample from an asteroid
and lift off of osiris-rex the 800
million dollar
asteroid hunting robot began chasing
bennu four years ago
we have arrived
but right away the asteroid surprised
loretta's team
we thought the surface was going to be
sandy and beach like and then i saw
those first images coming in
and i thought oh boy we're in for a real
challenge here
bennu is covered in boulders to find a
safe spot to grab a sample
scientists spent a year mapping every
square inch
they settled on this small clearing
called nightingale crater
and there's a large rock on the eastern
rim that i call mount doom
that's about 10 meters or 30 feet tall
and we definitely don't want to fly into
that
the spacecraft is about the size of a
large van it has to maneuver into an
area the size of a few parking spaces
its 11 foot long
arm ends with a sort of space vacuum
cleaner
designed to collect about two ounces of
asteroid gravel
the robot will spend all of 10 seconds
on bennu
before backing away the most intriguing
part
to me of the mission is the the
excitement
of bringing a sample back to earth
lori glaze nasa's director of planetary
science
it's almost like discover the the dna of
the universe
right it's exactly like discovering the
dna of the universe by
our at least the dna of our solar system
because this is the material that
actually built up who we are
here today potentially a cosmic jackpot
it would land in utah in 2023.
for cbs this morning mark strassman
atlanta
boy that's fascinating i was going to
say mark straussman had a lot of wowser
moments in that package
cosmic jackpot i like what they said i
like that what they said anthony it took
a year to find the right sample
all the work that goes into doing and
they make it look so easy and that
one brief moment that it's actually on
the asteroid picking up a couple of
ounces of material
the dna of the universe i think there's
somebody out there right now a little
child
looking at that going i want to do that
yeah i want to do that
bravo tonight and a half billion years
old bravo bravo